unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
[Applause]
welcome back to cbs this morning that's
a profound reaction there is lawyers and
members of
george floyd's family learned about
yesterday's verdict
look at the happiness in that room we
are joined by philonous floyd that's
george floyd's brother
his younger brother by the way along
with floyd family attorney that of
course is benjamin crump
good morning to you gentlemen i wonder
i'm wondering if either one of you got
any sleep yes last night i'm wondering
what it's like
to be on cloud nine this morning
ben it feels great
i did manage to get a couple of hours of
sleep and i was very happy for lunus
had was able to get some sleep because
he had not been sleeping
no i'm sure philones take us to that
moment when you heard the verdict it's
our understanding that you were praying
as you were waiting for the verdict to
be announced
take us when you heard the verdict and
what it was like for you in that room
last night
oh god before i even went into the
courtroom i was pacing back and forth
and ben and my wife were like
hey just be comfortable do what you have
to do and
the moment that i got in the courtroom
i started praying and i prayed for like
30 minutes because it took 30 minutes
for the judge and the jury to come out
but the moment i heard
guilty guilty
and guilty i was excited i was happy
because african-american people we feel
that we
never get justice we feel like it's just
us all the time
ben if i can follow up on that to that
point to philonous's point we heard the
minnesota attorney general afterwards
say
this is not justice yet but this is
accountability
what do you make of that
no i agree completely because uh
philonous floyd and the floyd family
have become the comforters
and counselors to dante wright's family
who tragically uh was killed
while the derek shogun trial was going
on and when we did
the first press conference jointly his
mother katie wright said
that justice would be my son
coming back to my front door with that
beautiful smile on his face
so we can never get justice but what we
can get is accountability
ben so much of this trial hinged on the
fact that not only do you have that nine
minutes and 30 seconds
of videotape cell phone video i should
say
but the fact that police officers
actually testified against one of their
own
moving forward how do you see that
opening up for other officers testifying
in future trials
in future cases like this
you know that was such an unusual moment
it was very
powerful to see the police come in and
testify
against a police officer in their
department
something i had never seen in my
professional career
and our prayer our fervent prayer part
of george floyd's legacy
is that this will be a precedent that we
have
people go do what they want people in
our community to do all the time they
say if you see
something illegal or unjust they want us
to tell
well the police can be the example for
us in the community
you know ben i think it's interesting
everybody is talking about darnella
frazier in that video
because if she hadn't had that video we
would never know about this
i i remember you hearing talking about
what the initial police report said was
very
different than what actually happened
that day on that street
yes ma'am gary king because so often the
standard police narrative
is well we're going to justify the
police actions
and people just accept it because
everybody wants to believe the police
and that first police report said
nothing about them having their knee on
george's neck about
them having their knees in his back it
said he was resisting
arrest and he died of natural causes
that's what the first report said hey
filonas
it's tony decouple i think i know
looking forward what the future holds
for ben crump he's going to continue
working on cases
like this one but for you you were
drafted into this movement
by the tragedy that happened to your
brother so i'm curious
does this end now for you as a movement
what will you do next
like i said once before this is a
fraternity that
i didn't ask to be in and unfortunately
you have a lot of families they need
counseling they need
somebody to get out and speak for them
because they may not be able to because
people be in a lot of pain dante wright
mom
it took her a while she just sat there
and she just cried because
she had the process that her son has
really been taken away
10 miles from where i was in the
courthouse
trying to make sure these officers be
held accountable
benjamin crump he has taken this case
and he will get justice but justice is
not justice for her
she because she said justice is my son
being able to come home
and i'll be able to hug him but we have
to make sure
that everybody is held accountable and
i started my institution called the
philonous and key to floyd institution
for social change
and i'm turning my pain into purpose to
be able to get out
and help others all across this world
not just here in minneapolis
but everywhere in different countries
too
well many people are hoping that this is
a change that they've been waiting for
before we go ben how is little gianna
floyd doing
well you know she was in the courtroom
with us
and attorney student attorney miller her
mother
and she was just lighting up the room
with her smile
yeah she's joy that's george he's in her
she smiles she laughs everything like
george
we'd like to know that thank you both
very much